hey 42 here we all know the old saying
crime doesn't pay but once you started
down the path of a criminal lifestyle it
can be pretty hard to get out of since
it's not y-you can just write your boss
away to a resignation I'll go and tell
the police that you're retiring but not
only is it possible some prolific
criminals have even gone on to become
very successful in some other fields of
mainstream work so let's have a look at
the top 7 criminals who left their life
of crime behind and became successful
legitimately we're starting with a
superstar a man recognized all around
the world for his music his business
empire and for being part of one of the
world's most famous couples it is of
course Shawn Carter more commonly known
as jay-z these days he's estimated to be
worth around 500 million dollars and has
a finger in so many pies he might as
well own a bakery as one of the greatest
rappers of all time he sold over 100
million records but he also runs a
record label a clothing brand a
fragrance line and even a sports agency
you'd think he'd just retire and play
golf or something
but no he keeps on going it's more
likely that he just has that
entrepreneurial spirit and that never
dies out so where did he learn this
where did he get his impressive business
skills from well as a teenager he was a
drug dealer known in the neighborhood as
jazzy the projects he came from were
gripped by the crack cocaine epidemic
and young Shawn saw it as one of the few
opportunities available to him as a way
to improve his situation he says that
later in his life he looked back and
realized the effects that the drugs had
on the community but at the time he was
just a kid thinking about surviving and
buying clothes so he took it upon
himself to learn business on the streets
jay-z says he owes most of his business
skills now and his ability to budget
thanks to his experiences dealing drugs
on the streets of New York in the 1980s
I guess working out a budget for a drug
deal probably makes you learn a lot
quicker than sitting in a classroom
listening to your business professor
monotonous lis explaining
Spreadsheets his past is a big part of
his music and he has plenty of great
songs about it such as friend or fro
from his first album reasonable doubt
and then fourth of December on the black
album which gives a perfect overview of
his rags to riches story I wonder if
he'll ever release an album about how to
sit through board meetings or the best
way to manage an investment portfolio
perhaps he could call it the green album
from one of the coolest men on the
planet to one of its truest geeks kevin
Mitnick was a hacker in the early 90s
known as both the Condor and the
darkside hacker he didn't think of it as
hacking though he liked to call it
social engineering
just like how Breaking and Entering
gives alternative access engineering
he started out engineering himself free
rides on the buses around LA after
sorting out how to bypass the punch card
system it's not exactly the most
gangster of beginnings but hey we all
got to start somewhere right
but he soon graduated to hacking into
multinational businesses by Pacific Bell
IBM Nokia and Motorola in 1988 he was
convicted for 12 months for breaking
into the Digital Equipment corporations
Network and copying their software but
this bad boy didn't hang up his keyboard
and was arrested in 1995 after almost
three years on the run it took four
years to get to trial but he was
ultimately convicted of multiple counts
of wire fraud and Computer Fraud he did
eight months in solitary confinement as
the prosecution implied that he caused
quote-unquote start a nuclear war by
whistling into a payphone his crimes are
likely quite exaggerated though and
probably many people involved in the
case itting quite understands the
technical side of things think about how
hard your grandma finds it to send the
text and then imagine she's on the jury
of a hacking trial it's gonna be a long
slow case it's only in recent years that
law enforcement has grown more
accustomed to the intricacies of
cybercrime eventually though kevin
Mitnick decided to use his powers for
good he became a successful security
consultant for major corporations and
the FBI teaching them about the great
mysteries of social and
nearing now he's legitimate he will
never be locked away from his beloved
internet again Mitnick now makes a very
comfortable living providing penetration
testing services for the world's largest
companies now our next man was much
harder to catch although he did spend a
year in prison in Ohio he is one of the
greatest drivers of all time NASCAR
legend jr. Johnson also nicknamed the
last American hero he was a phenomenal
NASCAR driver winning 50 of 313 races
and he was thrilling to watch as well
with a helful everstyle
that meant he would either walk off with
first place or just a steering wheel if
he was lucky he retired in his prime at
since the thrill had gone out of it he
said if my car didn't tear up there
wasn't anyone that could outrun me and
he was right so what was his crime
Junior Johnson was a bootlegger and he
used to drive moonshine all around North
Carolina
that's illegally made booze for those of
you who don't know his father spent a
third of his life in prison so little
Junior Johnson started learning from a
very early age how to outrun the law and
he was a nifty driver by the age of 10
running up and down a dirt roads near
his house and it was this reckless
driving style that made him great early
on in his career his car wasn't as fast
as the others but he was one of the
first drivers to used a technique of
going into the slipstream of a faster
car and then slingshotting around it
a practice which is common today Junior
Johnson made it so legit that he even
managed you have his record wiped clean
since the day after Christmas in 1986
President Ronald Reagan gave him a
presidential pardon for his old days as
a moonshine runner to be fair it was
Boxing Day so the president was probably
feeling pretty good about the idea of
someone bringing him more booze no
matter where it came from running
illegal booze has a sort of romantic
charm to it but once you get into the
hardest of the magic sort of disappears
now if I asked you what actor Tim Allen
was doing in column
with some magical white powder you maybe
think he was filming another sequel to
the santa claus but in october 1978 at
the airport he was actually arrested for
transporting over half a kilo of cocaine
that's right the voice of Buzz Lightyear
the squeaky-clean Space Ranger was a
drug dealer Allen had just started out
as a stand-up comedian but smuggling 650
grams of coke is no joke and he was
staring down the barrel of a life
sentence he sensibly decided that he
didn't want to spend to infinity and
beyond behind bars and took up the cops
offer of becoming an informant and got a
reduced sentence of three to seven years
and eventually just served 28 months
when he came out he returned to stand-up
comedy and went on to become one of the
biggest names in television with his
show home improvements he was so big at
one point that he set an impressive
record of having in one week the
top-rated show home improvements the
biggest grossing film the Santa Clause
and the New York Times best-selling book
don't stand too close to a naked man he
probably thought that all these
Christmases had come at once
he's estimated to be worth over 80
million dollars these days so it's safe
to say that crime doesn't pay
voicing little toys basement does though
our next criminal was also an actor but
not the kind who does movies Frank
Abagnale was one of the world's greatest
con men and among many other roles
fraudulently plays the part of a doctor
a lawyer and an airline pilot if this
all sounds slightly familiar it's
probably because his life was
immortalized on the big screen in the
movie catch me if you can starring
Leonardo DiCaprio and Tom Hanks directed
by Steven Spielberg
he was born in 1948 in New York and by
15 he had begun his first con on his dad
some of us might have stolen a beer or
two out of the fridge or helps lose a
bit of cash laying around the house but
Frank Julia took Frank senior for $3,400
by using his
card to buy car parts and then cashing
them in he said it was for date money
but that's an awful lot of popcorn soon
he graduated from defrauding the bank of
dad and started going after the real
ones by editing checks creating fake
identities and even putting his own
account details on blank deposit slips
so customers would accidentally place
their money into his account
the name conman is short for confidence
man
and it's really this ability that made
him so good at what he did often the
idea itself was so simple but just doing
it with authority and confidence meant
that he would get away with some
incredibly simple scams in one Bank he
noticed that employees from United
Airlines unhurt would come in with
ziplock bags and placed them in a drop
box so Frank port an out of order sign
on the box and a note saying to give the
money to the security guard instead and
guess who is hiding behind that security
guards uniform after a long chase by the
police and a lengthy list of fake
professions Frank was finally caught in
France
still only 21 years old so how did he
turn his life around well after five
years of his 12 year sentence the US
government released him on the condition
that they could use his hard-earned
expertise to help them track over
fraudsters he eventually ended up acting
as a consultant for major banks showing
them how he got around their security
and then designing better ways for them
to protect themselves I don't know some
people might say that working for major
banks means he hasn't really left a
common business after all a lot of the
people we talked about today are a bit
of a surprise you wouldn't look at him
Allanon guest drug dealer but our next
guy has made a career as an actor for
the very fact that he kind of looks like
a hardened criminal and that's because
he was big bads Danny Thao has been
playing gangsters since 1985 and is one
of the most prolific American actors
performing in at least four films a year
since the 90s you need a big scary
gangster done is your map you'll see him
striding around and
Robert Rodriguez or Tarantino film from
desperado to machete and dusk till dawn
what he's not just in it for the fame
and money he still plenty of student and
independent projects for just a price of
a tank of fuel and a hot dinner so why
is Danny Trejo so good at playing good
badass in films because Danny was a bona
fide badass he grew up in LA's Echo Park
and was consistently in and out of jail
for things like armed robbery
he ended up facing the death penalty for
throwing a rock at the head of a police
officer although he says he was aiming
at someone else whilst in jail he taught
himself to box and went for a drug
rehabilitation program which helped him
turn his life around and become a drug
counselor himself on leaving the pen and
it was counseling that got him into the
movie business
he went to mentor a kid who was
struggling with all the cocaine on the
set of runaway train it turned out that
the screenwriter recognized him from
when they'd done time together at San
Quentin prison and he was asked to train
an actor in boxing and then was given a
part as a boxer himself who needs
LinkedIn when you've got prison buddies
a and prison is still a part of Danny's
life he's told journalists that he still
sometimes worries that he'll wake up in
his cell with the bell ringing for
dinner time it was all a dream Danny all
a dream and finally we come to a man who
soundtracked many a romantic evening
with his deep bassy voice Barry White is
one of the best-selling artists of all
time and although he's famous as a
singer he's actually had his hand in
over a hundred and thirty gold and
platinum selling albums and singles he
was a songwriter composer producer and
session musician as well as a singer he
worked for bands such as the banana
splits Bob and Earl and Lisa Stansfield
as well as having his own huge solo hits
like the massive can't get enough of
your love babe so what is Berry's
criminal past well before he was
stealing hearts Barry White was stealing
cars the great soul singer was born in
Texas but like Danny Thao he grew up in
the troubled neighborhoods of LA
his brother Darrell was murdered in a
gang dispute and Barry rolled into jail
at 16 for stealing $30,000 of Cadillac
tires whilst he was in jail he heard the
famous Elvis tune it's now or never and
he took the message to heart deciding to
make a change in his life he left jail
after four months and left his life of
crime in the dust to become the legend
that we know today he sadly died it just
58 largely because he was overweight for
most of his adult life so any of you
criminals out there looking for a career
change I hope this has given you some
inspiration or perhaps after hearing
these success stories you're now
considering giving up your business
degree to deal drugs but please don't if
these stories tell us anything is that
legitimate work pays much more than
crime well in the long run at least
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you